being led up in the office to apply
water to corporate both of our ownership
and leverage taking protectors that out
those average
[Music]
so like I know what I'm trying to do I'm
I said before maybe furnace I'm trying
to build the biggest building in town
and my big strategy on that is none of
this going to build the biggest building
and I just genuinely believe that 95% of
people that look like me
their strategies appear that everybody's
going yeah of course that's it and
that's why I think I'll win because I
think I'm capable of building the
biggest building
[Music]
it's 11:30 internal meetings all day I'm
sure irises b-roll the [ __ ] out of it
just meeting after meeting after meeting
go no senior one now yeah
[Music]
[Music]
here inside the bush
there you wrote crush desert rages
exactly where we are you know it's
really cool when you put out content or
you write like if you end up being
historically correct it's really a
mystery
it's very impactful you're right yeah I
saw it I saw it only because it's
history repeating itself like I knew
this was going to become the platform
when the ground changes everything
changes and so it's not little shifts
they're big shifts there's a very
interesting dynamic with me which is
which is I push a lot of people to stop
consuming me I just want people to
reverse-engineer themselves if they can
help it
I'm amazingly self-aware and I'm
grateful for it it's been one of the
drivers of my success people struggle
with me there's something in the way
that I communicate that is really an
incredible mirror on the other person
here's the punch line figure yourself
out love yourself instead of beating up
yourself because we all have
unbelievable amounts of shortcomings so
why not focus on what you're decent hat
and [ __ ] go do I really enjoyed to
hear yourself talk you soon one hyper
minute very slightly pretty yeah I'm
very much in the bleeding that you why
create the vulnerability of not right
right it's actually not practical yeah
definitely right that's right you know
what and not for anybody in the
that's hard to hide yo doing the right
things always the right thing Tyler you
like the iris like you might want to use
my own Chloe awesome but if you are weak
at any time hey Joe Monica - you guys
want to build a personal brand or you
guys want to build the brand of the
compass we're all over it
well no it's a very very very important
distinction both work there's a million
reasons to do one or the other
personality traits how you even feel
about you may feel the mark the business
itself is positioned in an awkward way
and you actually don't want to be out in
for like is it as a myth book you want a
one day like 40 books you want to get
paid $100,000 to give a speech I don't
know unbelievably I don't care I think
that if I'm going to help you and I want
to help you that's the first question
it's a long play it will change the
course of your life
[Music]
everybody this is gary vay-ner-chuk and
this is episode 257 of the askgaryvee
show
I'm real excited you're here and I
believe that your show and you were
powerful for that because I do believe
when I watch it as a person I will
always win in business if if they listen
they will win well you know what I wear
this every failing businesses bailing on
Gary it's only known as if all so so if
they have a failing owner after 147 bar
rescues you know guys like you and I
learn everything about success yeah what
do you do to be succesful a success new
classes success over after 147 bar
rescues Gary I've see the depth of
failure abilities yeah you know what I
believe you and what's really funny to
me is you're gonna destroy it
you're destroy you have to push it you
know it's you you're a limited listen it
comes natural to you you made a line in
the sand and get clean and select the
second I guess live I did with my health
right I was like all I can I get and
then I did and I was like wow it's the
same [ __ ] that like you will crush it my
pleasure money continued success
[Music]
so guys 908 p.m. Tuesday night
being a sports team my episode for
command of the abscess tropics you check
it out binge watch the first four
episode I dominate episode 1 for the day
of operations just classic windup sort
of daily be nondescript the kind of
episode that a lot of us don't remember
that we're going to talk about there's
no [ __ ] quote amazing moment from it
just [ __ ] head down operation here
$150,000,000 manor excellent a company
pure well vaynermedia and that's just
the way I like it right like at the end
of the day I probably take more pride in
these episodes where there's nothing
great oh yeah I've put on a suit I've
gotta weigh every way so that'll be cool
maybe that's the most descripting but I
really enjoy this I really want to stop
the key any excuses on remind people
this is a real grind a real effort you
know there's no staging there's no
something like iris and I [ __ ] live
in it I mean like iris yeah literally
like 90% of today I was like see a
company I have covered it and I'm sorry
I can't share everything few people's
private lives finances
it's a client stock I was reviewing the
piece of business today like
I don't think you guys realize that 89%
of time you don't see me is running the
business or spend time with my family
so like get insights get to see it I
give you as much as I can
you know right
[Music]
and
you
[Music]